he seems to be the trouble of Chapman
I've been commissioned to adapt my novel
for the screen but the words have dried
up
I need to find intervention me down
maybe here bonsoir tonight I will use my
precious mystical gift I'd like you to
conduct ourselves at my home this
Thursday the moon is full we must
harness its power perfect though
pandemic art is a fraud you said to
yourself
it'll be superb inspiration for my new
screenplay is anybody there
oh that you Maya my spirit guide she was
Tutankhamun's wetness hope she's not
still lactating
is it anyone on the other side did you
think of Elvira is dead ex-wife I'd have
to go into a trance
Alethea hello you're dead ghost of my
first wife is here with us in the room
surely you can see her she's standing
right next to you drunk who's she
my wife I'm your wife not anymore you
can't he by any chance
gotcha I sincerely hope not it's not a
coincidence that you haven't published a
word since my demise there's the first
act of my screenplay
Elvira helped me she's dangerous Charles
you're the one I know I haven't the
foggiest idea how to send her back
you're in trouble now
to true love true love never die suta
must have gone hideously wrong
[Music]
it's not for the first time something
took place I can feel it in my base
chakra probably trapped wind
you